as the nation marks one million covet
deaths we want to draw your attention to
a stunning statistic it's estimated that
each death has a significant impact on
as many as nine people a new book called
the modern loss handbook is an
interactive guide for moving through
grief and building resilience author
rebecca sofer lost her mother in a car
crash 16 years ago four years later her
father died suddenly after struggling to
manage her own grief sofa co-founded her
own online community to help others
through the process rebecca sofer is
joining us now good morning to you thank
you for being here thank you so much for
having me you know it's interesting we
talk about grief i think even with kids
at a younger age so people know they
know the steps but why the need then to
have a handbook still anyway because we
still kind of suck at this conversation
i mean can we use that word on morning
news shows i think so we do a really bad
job at normalizing something that is
just one of the most normal human
experiences that a person can have i
mean if we're gonna love anybody that's
alive we're gonna grieve them when
they're gone and we kind of get hit we
get bogged down and like all the right
things that we should be saying and the
platitudes that were fed and like that
doesn't end up helping anybody it
doesn't help yeah like you said this is
not an old school grief book no angels
pastels no kittens and you like kittens
no toxic positivity or suggestions to
find gratitude in everything what do you
mean toxic positivity i mean like you
know the the the insistence with like
that gritted smile of like no bad days
with like the prayer hands and if you
want to use prayer hand emojis that's
fine like i'm not judging i'm talking
about the intent behind it which is like
if you're closed to hearing somebody's
actual story of what's actually going on
you're probably forcing some toxic
positivity down their throat there are
bad days yeah there are bad days even
ten years down the line that's okay and
it's not just okay it's like a normal no
you said sometimes rebecca it's okay to
be on the floor and it's not a heap and
that's all right listen i like the less
pithy ways but accurate stages of grief
total poop show oh wow i think i'm
totally fine sheer panic i hate people i
need people no i actually do hate people
right this is an accurate flowchart like
in one side of my brain
yes yes yes and you know you experience
all those things sometimes in one day
sometimes in one hour and sometimes over
the course of just like the entire arc
of the experience and you know i'm just
trying to show again like it all points
toward
this is all normal like as long as
you're not hurting yourself or anybody
else in the process
what just you do you you do grief your
own way i think people can tell this is
an irreverent guide there are stickers
in the back there's something called sad
libs uh but i i'm curious for people uh
who are confronting other people meeting
other people who are going through this
process how do you signal that thing
that you think is so important that
you're open to hearing whatever the
reality is yeah i mean we were talking
about this earlier and i think that we
get so overwhelmed by like we're look
this is the united states we like fixing
things we like having the fix we like
making things better you can't make it
better for another person if they've
lost somebody they love all you can do
is show up for them and make it clear
that whatever they're going through
you're aware that it's not contagious
grief is not contagious that's a message
i'd like to get through
by sharing your story with someone
you're not going to make them sadder
you're not going to like make it so that
that's going to happen to them and if
you just make it clear that you know
you're willing to sit with them in a
place that's really uncomfortable
sometimes sad sometimes ragey sometimes
darkly hilarious and sit with them
through it that is what they need they
need acknowledgement they need to feel
like they're being seen in something
really hard you said that grief is
exhausting and draining and you could be
grieving for everyone can be grieving
the same person differently yeah but i i
saw so many things that i've done wrong
reading your book by the way i think you
know it is irreverent but it also is
very serious you give us some practical
things when somebody is at work and they
return back to work the worst thing you
can say is how are you
i think how many times have we all done
that rebecca what's your name
yeah no okay so i'd like to say that i
screw up on a daily basis not only in
every how are you in life but how are
you doing i think it's more about like
anchoring something in time you know
like i've gotten a lot of hands on my
shoulders with like how are you like in
the stairwells and i feel very cornered
and i feel like it's really incumbent
upon me to share that i'm completely
fine because the person doesn't actually
want to know or they feel uncomfortable
and i think that when you ask more
specific questions like how are you
doing today how's today for you um you
know hey i i see that there's an
anniversary coming up like mother's day
like anchoring something those are
triggering things yeah and just be aware
of that and just say i know this is
coming like i'm here to talk i'm here to
text you know it's not that hard to show
meaningful support and actually be there
yeah grief milestones are cool time
machines i thought your book was so good
so good and you said when all else fails
you can just say to the person it's nice
to see you yeah it's i thought it's nice
to see you i could say gayle definitely
means it because she's actually uh
taking my book
i'm gonna send it to somebody
all else up yes that's true it kind of
helps as you said get everybody out of
their own heads when it comes to this
thank you so much for being here thank
you we obviously all enjoyed the book
and modern lost handbook if gayle's not
bringing you a copy don't go on sale
tuesday you can get your hands on it